auf dem weg ins wochenende sage ich
hallo deutschland freue mich dass sie
dabei sind auch bei unserem corona
kompakt da gehen wir heute mit einer
polizei auf streife ich sage nur kontakt
sperren kontrolle astronaut alexander
gerst er gibt tipps gegen die einsamkeit
zu hause und die psychologie professorin
ulrike lügen aus berlin die beantwortet
viele fragen
zunächst aber nach thüringen dort sind
die bewohner eines ganzen pflegeheims
mit corona infiziert corona alarm in
einem altenpflegeheim im sächsischen
zwönitz mindestens 84 senioren und
pfleger sind mit dem coup 19 virus
infiziert zwei menschen sind hier
bereits gestorben
fürs heim ist natürlich dramatisch für
die menschen die dort wohnen die es
betroffen sind weil es muss im
pflegeheim sind die alle natürlich
risikogruppe und kann nur hoffen dass
dort wenig todesfälle auftreten dass die
krankheitsverläufe nicht so
schwerwiegend sind
der landrat des erzgebirgskreises geht
allerdings von einer verschlimmerung der
lage aus er rechnet mit weiteren toten
verschiedene deutsche pflegeheime sind
von corona infektionen betroffen
zwönitz ist bis jetzt der schlimmste
fall damit rutschen wir natürlich
insgesamt in der statistik sehr sehr
weit nach vorne was jetzt
deutschlandweit jetzt die fallzahlen
sind pro 100000 einwohner und die
betrachten wir immer das macht das
robert-koch-institut auch so nach
erhebungen der johns hopkins universität
sind in deutschland stand heute 16 30 85
1903 infektionen durch tests bestätigt
22 1440 menschen gelten als genesen
damit diese zahlen sich verbessern
stellt das robert-koch-institut klar
stoffmasken könnten dabei helfen andere
zu schützen
aber sie helfen nicht dabei den
maskenträger selbst zu schützen
die wichtigste regel aber bleibt abstand
halten wer also zum beispiel auf die
geburtstagsparty verzichtet der könnte
sich mit einem autokorso feiern lassen
wie dominik heidenheim also auch in
zeiten von corona die ganz ganz große
party aber die muss nicht nur bei den
heidenheims aufs nächste jahr verschoben
werden
vielleicht neuer trend mit dem heutigen
freitag da haben die meisten schulen und
kitas wegen der korona epidemie jetzt
schon drei wochen lang geschlossen an
lange zeit und für nicht wenige kinder
eine zum teil dramatische und auch
gefährliche zeit wenn man sich nämlich
bewusst macht dass schon in normalen
zeiten kindesmisshandlungen und
vernachlässigung zu nehmen die
kernfamilie ist auf sich selbst
zurückgeworfen alltag und freizeit
finden fast ausschließlich zu hause
statt eine große herausforderung schon
für funktionierende familien proben
office und hausaufgabenbetreuung
gleichzeitig und das ganze auf engem
raum
wenn eltern dem stress und der
überforderung nur seelische oder
körperliche gewalt entgegensetzen können
wird so eine situation vor allem für
kinder zur hölle und der druck steigt
durch lagerkoller und zukunftsängste
sagt rainer rettinger vom deutschen
kinder verein nun wir wissen dass in
china in der zeit der quarantäne
die gewalt um das dreifache zugenommen
hat und wir wissen ähnliches auch von
italien und spanien und befürchten dass
eben für deutschland auch
2018 in einem normalen jahr mit normalem
sozialleben gab es 4180
kindesmisshandlungen 136 kinder starben
die kinder können nicht einmal mehr
fliehen schule als sicheres umfeld
geschlossen spielplatz um frust und
angst weg zu spielen geschlossen
freunde besuchen um wenigstens kurz mal
vergessen zu können kontaktsperre zudem
haben manche erziehungs und
beratungsstellen schon zu gehören
von heimen die geschlossen wurden und
die kinder wurden zurückgeschickt in die
problematischen familien all das macht
uns große sorge und für kinder kann das
eine lebensgefährliche situation sagen
und die kinder haben zusätzlich angst
weil sie meist gar nicht genau verstehen
was gerade in der welt los ist der
verdachtsfälle bemerkt kann sie beim
jugendamt melden das geht auch anonym
bei akuter gefahr sollte man die polizei
einschalten
nur eines sollte man nie tun wegschauen
wir dürfen nicht sagen
nein es geht mich nichts an ich halte
mich da raus nein bitte nicht denn wenn
wirklich etwas passiert und ich habe
etwas davon mitbekommen und sage es
nicht dann ist es unterlassene
hilfeleistung und damit könnte ich
persönlich nicht leben zurzeit ist
gewalt im öffentlichen raum nicht mehr
sichtbar und im öffentlichen raum auch
nicht mehr korrigierbar
sie findet nur noch hinter
verschlossenen türen statt eine
situation die von uns allen zivilcourage
erfordert
ja da tut es gut experten zu haben die
beraten können und helfen können in
solchen fällen wie frau professor ulrike
lügen psychologin an der humboldt
universität in berlin hallo in die
hauptstadt
ich grüße sie herr professor lügen was
kann man denn tun wenn man selber das
gefühl hat dass es in unmittelbarer
umgebung zu häuslicher gewalt kommt das
ist ein ganz wichtiger punkt den sie da
ansprechen denn in der jetzigen zeit
müssen viele menschen auch sehr beengten
raum miteinander auskommen und das kann
zu gefühlen von aggression und leider
eben auch zu häuslicher gewalt führen
genauso wie angst ist aggressionen auch
ein grundgefühl dass jeder mensch kennt
aggression signalisiert uns dass eine
grenze überschritten worden ist ja aber
wichtig zu verstehen ist dass aggression
nicht automatisch zu gewalthandlungen
führen muss wenn sie selber also merken
dass diese gefühle in denen hochkochen
dann begeben sie sich sofort aus der
situation geben sie sich und ihren
angehörigen eine auszeit ja und wenn sie
dann wieder etwas runter gefahren sind
versuchen sie darüber nachzudenken
welche grenze ist denn bei mir verletzt
worden wenn sie aber zeuge von
häuslicher gewalt werden dann sollten
sie in jedem fall die polizei rufen
vielen dank für diese wichtigen tipps
und einschätzungen und danke fürs erste
denn sie bleiben ja unser heutiger
corona kompakt gast und beantworten
später noch weitere fragen also bis
gleich in diesen tagen die heimischen
händler hat zu unterstützen das ist
gerade jetzt wichtiger denn je um so
deren überleben zu sichern
aber abgesehen vom essen zum mitnehmen
oder gutscheinen vielleicht hier und da
auch gar nicht so leicht die händler im
thüringischen mühlhausen die setzen
deshalb auf ihren online marktplatz den
haben sich schon vor einiger zeit
gegründet doch jetzt ist daraus eben die
chance geworden die krise gemeinsam zu
überstehen
in der touristen information mühlhausen
herrscht betrieb auch wenn die türen
geschlossen sind
[Musik]
lachen zusammen zurzeit kommen keine
touristen um sich zu informieren
auch die meisten veranstaltungen sind
erst mal ausgesetzt
doch was im laden steht kann weiterhin
gekauft werden vom bekannten mühlhäuser
pflaumenmus bis hin zu herzhaften
thüringer spezialität gerade jetzt in
zeiten wo die dosen auch in den
supermärkten wirklich sehr beliebt sind
es auf unsere bratwurst eine dose der
absolute verkaufsschlager dass sie trotz
geschlossenen ladentüren weiter produkte
verkaufen kann verdankt sie dem
mühlhäuser online marktplatz auf dieser
lokalen webseite können sich
einzelhändler aus der stadt kostenlos
registrieren
und ihre waren im internet anbieten etwa
50 geschäfte sind schon dabei unter
ihnen auch der schmuck laden von monika
witt ich dankbar seit 1930 besteht ihr
geschäft gegründet vom großvater nun ist
es zu die verkäuferin nutzt die zeit zur
inventur kein laden offen keine
einnahmen aber jeder kostenfaktor geht
weiter ich weiß nicht wie es geht aber
es wird funktionieren irgendwie so viel
vertrauen haben nicht alle
und obwohl die mühlhäuser plattform
schon seit einem halben jahr besteht zum
einkaufen nutzen sie bislang nur wenige
gehört habe ich es ja aber ich muss
gestehen ich war noch nicht drauf also
bestellt habe ich noch nicht
das schon eine option ich schaue auch
weil es bleibt einem nichts anderes
übrig wenn man sieht es ja ist ja geil
zu vielleicht dass man in so
krisenzeiten dann doch irgendwie sich
wieder darauf besinnt auf die händler
denn mein herz und sieht und man kennt
ja auch die leute in so einer kleinen
stadt
der anblick der leeren mühlhäuser
innenstadt macht auch dem bürgermeister
sorgen
er hofft sehr dass der online marktplatz
jetzt mehr genutzt wird und die händler
vielleicht sogar über die krise bringen
kann
es gibt es einfach darum dass die
größeren häuser auch regional einkaufen
und eben nicht bei amazon einkaufen wenn
im moment alle über solidarität reden
wäre es jetzt auch gut zu sagen wir
gucken was gibt es auf der regionale
plattform was ist möglich was ist da und
dass man zuerst hier schauten einkauft
deshalb versucht er noch mehr
einzelhändler für die regionale website
zu gewinnen
auch katja sternagel seit 19 jahren
verkauft sie mode in mühlhausen die
schließung ihres ladens trifft sie hart
über wasser halten sie derzeit nur
langjährige stammkunden die telefonisch
bei ihr bestellt ich stelle outfits
jedes individuell zusammen fotografiere
es schicke es hin
der kunde schickt es mir zurück dann
verpacke ich es und liefere es abends
nach feierabend aus auf facebook hat sie
außerdem zum kauf von gutscheinen
aufgerufen damit ihr geschäft überleben
kann
ob die geschäfte in der mühlhäuser
innenstadt die krise überstehen ist
unklar
die idee vom regionalen online shopping
könnte für den einzelhandel aber
immerhin eine chance sein wenn die
solidarität der käufer ausreicht und die
ohnehin gerade besonders gefragt die
solidarität von uns allen auch beim
umsetzen und aushalten der kontaktsperre
nicht immer leicht ich glaube das haben
wir mittlerweile wohl alle erfahren aber
eben notwendig wir haben die polizei in
leipzig dabei begleitet wie sie die
ausgangs und abstandsregeln kontrolliert
es ist einer jener ersten lauen
frühlingsabend die ein versprechen auf
mehr zu geben scheinen doch die
leipziger bereitschaftspolizisten sollen
hier im clara-zetkin-park kontrollieren
dass die frühlingslaune nicht überbordet
und die strengen ausgangs und kontakt
regeln eingehalten werden
da wird sogar das mini picknick von zwei
frauen kritisch beäugt sind die zwei von
hier und wird der mindestabstand
eingehalten alles in ordnung sagen
polizei und auch die kontrollierten
war vorhin orten und man ist auch nur
deren job herr will muss das beste aus
der situation machen und weiß nichts
schlimmes absolut über funk kommt der
nächste auftrag ganz am anderen ende der
stadt in einer wohnsiedlung in gronau
soll eine gaststätte illegal auf gemacht
haben und eine kleine menschengruppe
draußen beim bier zusammen stehen
eingreifen muss die polizei nicht das
ordnungsamt ist schon da heute gibt es
nur einen platzverweis eine anzeige
hätte 150 euro geldbuße gekostet doch
kollege bringt jetzt einen geworden
getaucht lassen wärmflaschen und geht
dann auch ja nach hause
es ist keine böse absicht es ist die
einsamkeit die die menschen aus ihren
wohnungen treibt das sind meine freunde
und geschmack müssen wir erhalten auch
immer abstand
was aber das tut sehr belastenden die
meisten ermahnten sind kooperativ
probleme hatte die polizei bisher kaum
die erfahrung sind unterschiedlich das
ist für alle eine vernünftige lösung
gibt die meisten spontanen partys finden
draußen statt wenn die polizei kommt
suchen die feiernden schnell das weite
die spuren aber sprechen für sich die
beamten setzten auf die abschreckende
wirkung der kontrollen
man wird ja auch immer wieder
angesprochen
das ist die lehre gut finden dass wir
das kontrollieren und auch durchsetzen
in der innenstadt leere wo sonst
touristen drängeln zeit durchzuschnaufen
und für die bitte um verständnis dass
auch gesetzeshüter nur menschen sind
natürlich können wir nicht alles wissen
und ich hoffe dass die bürger das auch
so sehen und uns vielleicht öfters mal
mit einem lächeln begrüßen anstatt mit
einem nicht so schönen gesicht oder so
also wieder die manuell börsenschluss
ist noch lange nicht die schicht endet
nicht vor drei uhr nachts das mit dem
lächeln ist ein guter hinweis sind auch
nur menschen die polizisten wie wir alle
und deshalb ist das mit kontaktsperre
isolation und den ausgefallenen besuchen
ja auch so schwer
aus diesem grund jetzt ein paar
exklusive tipps gegen das einsame fühlen
von jemanden der sich bestens damit
auskennt astronaut alexander gerst rund
400 kilometer von einem normalen büro
schreibtisch entfernt arbeitete der
deutsche astronaut alexander gerst 2018
ein halbes jahr lang war auf der
raumstation iss im einsatz weit weg von
familie und freunden gegen die
einsamkeit hilft vor allem mentale
vorbereitung soziale kontakte dank
internet kein problem im gegenteil die
viel größere herausforderung die
anhaltende präsenz von partnern und mit
bewohnern das leben ein problem auch für
dann kann man die eigentlich relativ
schnell lösen
die ungewohnte lage ist nicht nur last
sondern auch eine chance damit man hier
auf das negative schossen daneben auch
die möglichkeiten sich anschaut wie zum
beispiel dass man jede menge projekte
die man mentale kraft disziplin und vor
allem toleranz werden den zusammenhalt
stärken und helfen die korona krise zu
überwinden
diese tipps sagt gerst funktionieren im
weltall wie auf der erde gleichermaßen
gut
wir kommen zurück frau professor lügen
sage ich der psychologin an der humboldt
universität in berlin sie sind immer da
für unsere fragen und eine frage lautet
dass meine frau und ich jeden tag zu
hause sitzen gehen nur mal kurz raus zum
einkaufen und stadt langsam die decke
auf den kopf
was kann man dagegen tun ja wenn die
tagesstruktur die man sonst gewohnt war
auf einmal nicht mehr da ist dann fällt
ein sehr schnell die decke auf den kopf
also her gerst hat es ja auch gerade in
dem beitrag sehr schön dargestellt und
wichtig ist jetzt dass sie sich selber
eine neue struktur schaffen müssen
setzen sie sich mit ihrer partnerin
zusammen planen sie die nächsten tage
wie mit einem stundenplan in der schule
früher vielleicht und planen sie nicht
nur gemeinsame dinge ein sondern auch
zeit für sich selber denn wir sind es
gar nicht mehr so gewohnt so viel zeit
mit unseren partnerinnen und partnern zu
verbringen und insofern ist es gut doch
eine balance hinzubekommen
gut zu wissen wer die nächste frage die
uns erreicht hat ist eine steigerung ich
bin mit meiner ganzen familie zu hause
also wir haben zusätzlich drei kinder 3
7 und 12
die wollen auch raus und ihre freunde
treffen was können wir denn tun ihnen
die situation erträglicher zu machen
über den stundenplan hinaus kinder haben
natürlich ein starkes bedürfnis zu
spielen und sich auch körperlich zu
betätigen
das heißt wenn immer sie es ermöglichen
können dass kinder sich an der frischen
luft betätigen machen sie das möglich
vielleicht können sie auch wieder
gemeinsame familienaktivitäten einführen
also früher hat man spieleabende
veranstaltet ja und wenn der beste
freund die beste freundin fehlt
vielleicht können sie es ermöglichen
dass man sich per videochat
zusammenfindet und damit sich auch
untereinander gut unterstützen kann
unter den kindern und jugendlichen beim
nächsten fragensteller da sind die
kinder vier und acht jahre alt wie
erkläre ich denen die situation ohne
ihnen angst zu machen also kinder
bekommen ja momentan mit dass etwas
anders ist das heißt sie spüren die
angst und anspannung die wir erwachsenen
haben aber anders als wir haben sie
keine gute erklärung dafür
und deswegen ist es wichtig unseren
kindern das in kindgerechter form zu
erklären was gerade passiert ja
und dabei sollte man auch zuversicht
vermitteln länder
wesen einer jeden krise ist ja dass sie
zeitlich begrenzt ist und man muss auch
berücksichtigen dass kinder ein anderes
zeitempfinden haben sie kennen das
vielleicht selber vielleicht noch wenn
sie mit dem adventskalender die zeit bis
weihnachten überbrückt haben vielleicht
können sie gemeinsam mit ihren kindern
einen frühlings kalender führen damit
die kinder sehen wie viel tage noch
vorne sind aber wie viel tage auch schon
geschafft worden sind guter tipp ich bin
gespannt auf den nächsten die situation
auch für mich nächste woche mache home
office meine ganze familie ist zu hause
die kinder wollen beschäftigt werden
wie kann ich da eine klare abgrenzung
hinkriegen zwischen arbeit und familie
ja da muss auf jeden fall der
familienrat tagen also im familienrat
hat jedes mitglied eine stimme und sie
tauschen sich darüber aus welche
bedürfnisse und wünsche jeder hat also
kinder haben vielleicht das bedürfnis
nach gemeinsamer zeit und eltern haben
aber auch das bedürfnis und den wunsch
nach rückzug und zeiten für die arbeit
verhandeln sie das machen sie einen
zeitplan wer darf wann welche räume
vielleicht nutzen und versuchen sie
vielleicht auch einfach mal eine an ein
schild an die tür zu machen ich bin zur
arbeit und wenn sie geräusch abgelenkt
sind können manchmal auch kopfhörer sehr
hilfreich sein
eine frage schaffen wir noch fans geht
mit einer kurzen antwort da kann jemand
kein home office machen ich muss mich
jeden tag in der öffentlichkeit bewegen
und habe angst fast schon panik mich
anzustecken was tun
ja wahrscheinlich ist dass jemand der so
einen systemrelevanten beruf gerade für
uns alle ausübt und ich würde mir
einfach noch mal vergegenwärtigen was
die guten schutzmaßnahmen sind also
handhygiene abstand halten
und wenn sie das gefühl haben auf der
arbeit könnte man noch etwas verbessern
für ihren persönlichen schutz sprechen
sie mit kolleginnen kollegen sprechen
sie ihren arbeitgeber darauf an um die
situation für sie leichter zu machen
ganz herzlichen dank nach berlin frau
professor lücken für die antworten ja
und jeden tag neu da kümmern wir uns ja
hierbei alle deutschland im ganzen team
um ein aktuelles und informatives corona
kompakt dass dann auch immer über den
kanal der zdf heute auf youtube zu
finden ist kriegen sie gerne rein oder
wenn sie auch eine frage haben an unsere
experten schicken sie uns eine mail an
kroner kompakte zdf
am montag ist der virologe professor
plachta zu gast der dann einige fragen
hier beantworten wird